hi far meine Frage und zwar du hast in
deinem Videoblogs gezeigt dass du
ziemlich gut Fuball spielst und ich
wollte fragen was so dein
Lieblingsverein ist und ob du auch mal
selbst im Verein gespielt hast und
außerdem wollte ich noch wissen ob
irgendwann vielleicht auch mal das Album
neureiche Wixer kommen sollte was du ja
eventuell mal überlegt hattest mit fah
und Summerjam wä auf jeden Fall eine
coole Sache wenn du antwortest also
mach's
gut ich bin natürlich großer Fußballfan
Barcelona und Real Madrid das ist ein
Widerspruch in sich aber ich mag beide
Vereine ich bin aber mehr auf Barcelonas
Seite real finde ich aber auch gut ich
habe früher ganz früh so mit im Alter
von 13 Fußball
gespielt bei bv04 und dann habe ich
gewechselt so bv04 ist ein Fußballverein
in Düsseldorf dann bin ich gewechselt zu
dsc99 ich war so 15 Jahre alt und ich
war auch sehr gut der Trainer kam dann
zu mir nach Hause und meinte ey komm zum
Training du musst keinen Beitrag
bezahlen im Monat ich war auch
übermotiviert dahinzugehen das ist jetzt
keine gelogene Geschichte ich hatte
keine Fußballschuh und konnte mir keine
leisten und konnte so nicht zum Verein
gehen sonst wäre ich vielleicht heute
großer Fußballspieler geworden und zu
dem Album neureich Wixer ist momentan
nichts geplant aber ich denke jetzt
erstmal in nah Zukunft stehen so viele
andere Projekte aners jetzt wenn ich
jetzt sagen würde das kommt dann wäre es
total
gelogen